republicans are now claiming both some
kind of vindication
and some kind of cover-up because
president joe biden has
ordered a closer intelligence review of
the origins
of the covid 19 virus and pandemic
and biden revealed that earlier this
year per cnbc
he asked the intelligence community to
assess did it emerge
from human contact with an infected
animal or did it emerge from a
laboratory
accident increasingly there are more and
more
people saying we need to study whether
this was
man-made and it's really important to
understand
that these are different ideas and that
there is not a current belief that covid
was man-made and in fact
if it were based on the best medical
science i've read
it would have a different sort of
signature
that would be noticeable when you
examine
the virus now let's let's really
understand what is going to be examined
here which i think is great and by the
way
those claiming that the left never
wanted to look at this
go talk to the people who said that i
have said from the very beginning
investigate everything we want truth i
want truth
um but uh regardless the idea persists
that
the left doesn't want to know the truth
uh i very much want to know the truth so
option one
contact spread to humans from an
animal to humans likely in wuhan and
spread from there
scenario number two this came from
an animal and was being studied in a lab
possibly in wuhan and due to an accident
it leaked and spread there to the
worldwide human population
and then you have scenario three the
most conspiratorial and the one for
which we have no evidence
which is this was some some kind of a
human-made bio weapon that was
deliberately released into the wild by
china now
that first piece doesn't really pass the
sniff test in part because
it has been so damaging not only to
china
but to other countries around china that
china has no reason to try to go after
so the u.s centric nationalist view is
china would have been motivated to do
this in order to attack the u.s most of
the deaths have been elsewhere
i think globally officially there are
about 3.5 3.6 million cova deaths
and in the us there's officially 600
thousand that means that
five sixth of the deaths were elsewhere
and many in china
very would be a very very strange thing
to do now as a reminder
uh the biden administration has been
okay
uh investigating this for a long time
here is white house deputy press
secretary
karine jean-pierre two days ago saying
uh the biden administration has not
ruled anything out and is open to
exploring further
another question on uh kovid uh
the language that you all use
specifically mentioned an accident
does that mean that uh you've ruled out
or the ic has ruled out that it was
uh deliberate or not an accident we
haven't ruled out anything yet
um again we're going to go through this
you know this re-doubling down of
another
of a 90-day review and we'll have more
to share but yet
the idea will not go away that joe biden
doesn't want to investigate this
remember this is from earlier this week
we looked at these clips
this is from monday here is peter ducey
from fox news
asking white house press secretary jen
saki but why won't
joe biden look into it what will it take
for him to look into it
new investigation but with 589
920 dead americans at what point does
president biden say
we don't want to wait for the w.h.o we
don't know what they're doing this needs
to be an american-led
effort to get to the bottom of what
happened well first of all we need
access to the underlying data and
information in order to have that
investigation and
but he talks all the time about how he's
known president xi
for a long time so why can't he just and
we need them
for that information i think you're
misunderstanding how this process
actually works
an international investigation led by
the world health organization is
something that we've actually been
pressing for for
several months in coordination with a
range of partners around the world
we need that data we need that
information from the chinese government
what we can't do
and what i would caution anyone doing is
leaping ahead of an actual international
process
we don't have enough data and
information to jump to a conclusion at
this point in time
so is there any amount of the
casualties from colbit in this country
that would make you want to
not wait for an international effort and
just do it
as well i i have to say i think the
family members of the
loved ones whose lives have been lost
and deserve
accurate information data not the
jumping to a conclusion without having
the information necessary
to conclude what the origins are what we
do share everyone in this country as a
desire to know
how this started where it started and
prevent it from ever happening again
that's something we all share go ahead
and then not satisfied i guess with that
answer
asking the same question on tuesday
uh and getting a very similar answer
does president biden think these
theories we hear more about now that
kova 19 may have been man-made and
escaped from a lab in china
are a wacky conspiracy theory or based
on what he has heard and been briefed on
does he think that's possible
well we went through this journey
together yesterday so let's do it again
uh so the president believes there needs
to be an independent investigation
one that's run by the international
community it's an international pandemic
that has killed hundreds of thousands of
people around the world
he believes the chinese need to do more
to put forward data to be more
transparent and in the second phase of
this
effort he's certainly hopeful that will
be the case and he believes that every
theory should be explored through that
process but that we shouldn't jump to
conclusions before
that data and that information is made
available thank you and on the rise
so listen there's really no reason not
to
do this whether or not it was
engineered as some conspiracists claim
although we have no evidence for that at
this point in time why wouldn't we want
to find out more about the origins of an
infectious disease
that became a global pandemic completely
overtook us
uh and created the chaos that it did
over the last 16 17 months
so um again the best science i've read
is that had it been engineered by humans
it could not have been done with any of
the known tools of genetic manipulation
okay when you use the known tools
from genetic manipulation they leave
evidence
in the genome that's not there so
again applying some sort of occam's
razor here
if this was engineered it was engineered
in a way that it was done with
heretofore
unknown methods such that that
engineering is unable to be detected
that's a big leap and we don't have any
evidence of that
investigate it investigated wuhan was
researching
bat born coronaviruses and classifying
them and looking at mutation rates and
behaviors
so is it possible a tech got scratched
while they were working with these
samples it's plausible certainly
and it should be investigated the wet
market hypothesis from the beginning
quite plausible let's let's investigate
it uh but the
idea the fake scandal now that the right
is trying to create
that the left is unwilling to explore it
or that the left is covering it up
or that this is somehow dr fauci's fault
he
was involved in the creation to then
make money from the
uh solution you know there is no
evidence for any of those things and
absent that evidence we should just be
saying investigate do an investigation
now i saw a couple kind of weird
comments from some claiming to be on the
left
saying the lab leak hypothesis is racist
because it implies that chinese
scientists are just incompetent come on
guys
we're getting nowhere with that trash
okay
um accidents can happen anywhere for all
we know
it's not even all chinese scientists
that were working in that lab
it's that we're going down a really dumb
path to say
even exploring this is racist even
raising the question is racist
that's nuts assuming that it was any of
these things though
until we actually have some evidence
that's also not going to make any sense
to me send me your thoughts i'm on
twitter at dpakman
this is it guys monday memorial day it's
time for the one day membership special
okay we will do a one day huge
membership discount on the last day of
may and on federal holiday memorial day
if you want to get on the list to be
notified just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique
online service delivering the same
active
ingredients as viagra and cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra
boost of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around
no awkward conversations with your
doctor all of blue chews tablets are
made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping